when you started this this was not after  the Dobbs decision and now about to go  into theaters it is really reframed it  when I read this script I thought it was  a great Coming of Age story for a 40  year old woman and a political Awakening  for somebody who was asleep in their  life  somebody who never thought they would  have to seek abortion Health Care having  to do so and then really learning about  what that means for others who have to  walk that road and the Judgment that she  carried until she had to walk it she's  named joy and I just remember thinking  like there has to be a sense of  effervescence in this there has to be a  sense of a woman making a life affirming  choice and an empowered choice and  really taking control over her life and  I feel like we've done it really  beautifully in the movie and  she can't do it without the help of  these other incredible women the  collective in it was the collaborative  in it the process of making it it all  came together